si la matriz de transformación es igual
a 3 003 selecciona el esquema que puede
representar la transformación después de
aplicarla al cuadrilátero rojo duhau
este problema es fascinante date cuenta
de que no nos dan ningún as coordenadas
excepto los vértices del cuadrilátero
que bueno al final son unos puntos más
útiles cuando pensamos en
transformaciones potenciales así que
bueno pues vamos a empezar a trabajar
con este problema y bueno para ver qué
es lo que le está pasando a las
coordenadas particulares que tenemos
aquí y de eso estoy seguro que nos dará
suficiente información para poder pensar
en todo lo que hemos aprendido lo
primero que voy a querer que hagas es
que pause el vídeo y lo intentas hacer
por tu cuenta
darle algunos valores a las coordenadas
de los vértices de este cuadrilátero
rojo que tenemos aquí observa a dónde
vas a llegar después de aplicar esta
transformación y así podrás visualizar
cuál de estos esquemas se parece más al
resultado que obtuviste así que es buen
momento para que pausas
así que estoy asumiendo que ya pausa
hasta el vídeo y solo para decir como
motivo de la argumentación que este
punto de aquí y bueno para hacernos las
cosas más fáciles va a ser nuestro
vector posición el cual lo voy a
escribir como un vector columna y para
hacerlo más fácil vamos a decir que este
4 y latero es un cuadrado así que este
punto lo voy a bautizar con el vector
columna am lo voy a bautizar con el
nombre de 11 ok y bueno por aquí tenemos
a este vector columna 11 y por lo tanto
este otro vértice de aquí va a ser el
vector columna
1 - 1 estás de acuerdo y ahora este de
por acá va a ser el vértice que va a
tener asociado el vector posición a
menos uno menos uno ok menos 1 - 1 y
finalmente este punto de aquí de por
aquí lo podemos representar con el
vector posición menos 11 así que vamos a
ver qué es lo que pasa con la matriz de
transformación ya que va a transformar
estos puntos y bueno la forma en la que
voy a hacerlo es tomándome esta matriz
de transformación 3 003 y la voy a
multiplicar por una matriz de dos por
cuatro
presente todos estos valores posiciones
así que voy a multiplicar a esta matriz
por esta otra matriz que va a tener aquí
en su primer columna al vector 11
después tengo este punto de aquí que es
el vector uno menos uno con su
respectivo color después por acá tengo
al siguiente que es el vector menos 11
ok
este de color verde y para finalizar
aquí tengo a este otro que va a ser a mi
vector o bueno mi columna menos uno
menos uno y bueno estos puntos los tomé
a propósito para que las cuentas sean
más sencillas de realizar vamos a tener
y date cuenta esto es muy importante una
matriz de 2 por 2 que multiplica a una
matriz de 2 por 4 y bueno date cuenta
que la multiplicación de matrices
también definido aquí porque tenemos las
columnas de la primera matriz que son
iguales a las filas de la segunda y con
esto nos dará de resultado una matriz de
2 por 4 lo cual tiene mucho sentido pues
necesitamos cuatro columnas aquí para
que nos den las transformaciones de sus
puntos así que vamos a averiguar quién
son
esta primera entrada de aquí este de
aquí la vamos a obtener multiplicando en
lo que es la primera fila por la primera
columna de estas dos matrices si
quisiéramos por ejemplo la segunda
entrada tendremos que multiplicar la
segunda fila por la primera columna de
la segunda matriz así que vamos a
hacerlo pues me va a quedar 3 por 10 por
1 lo cual es 30 lo cual es 3 entonces
aquí voy a poner 3 y después tengo 0 por
uno más tres por uno lo cual es cero más
tres y eso otra vez nos da tres así que
aquí voy a poner de nuevo un tres y creo
que ya empieza a ver un patrón por aquí
ya que si queremos obtener la coordenada
en x para cada uno de estos vectores
entonces siempre vamos a involucrar esta
primera fila y si te das cuenta lo único
que hay que hacer es multiplicar 3 por
bueno cualquier valor que obtengamos
aquí en x ya eso no le vamos a sumar
nada ni va a desaparecer porque aquí
tenemos un cero y ese patrón se repite
se repite se repite por ejemplo si yo
quiero fijarme en mi segundo vector me
va a quedar 3 x 1 + 0 x menos 1
y otra vez nos va a quedar 30 lo cual es
3 y si te das cuenta acá abajo cuando
hablamos de la coordenada en quién va a
pasar algo muy parecido lo único que
vamos a hacer es involucrar la
coordenada en ya que tenemos aquí de
cada uno de nuestros vectores y lo vamos
a multiplicar por 3 fíjate bien nos va a
quedar 0 por 1 0 por la coordenada en x
por lo tanto siempre se va a eliminar mi
coordenada en x ya esto habrá que
sumarle tres veces la coordenada el 10
de cada uno de estos vectores es decir 3
x menos 1 lo cual es menos 3 y ya que
empieza a ver el patrón date cuenta que
lo único que estamos haciendo es
escalando por 3 cada uno de estos
vectores activa de nuevo me queda 3 x
menos uno lo cual es menos 3 ya esto le
voy a sumar 0 x 1 lo cual es 0 entonces
me quedan menos 3 y después tengo 0 por
lo que sea bueno esto no importa y
después 3 por 1 lo cual me va a dar 3 y
para finalizar tengo 3 x menos 1 lo cual
me va a dar menos 30 x menos 1 lo cual
es cero entonces en resumidas cuentas me
quedan menos 3 y para finalizar tengo 0
x menos uno más tres x menos uno lo cual
es
3 también y seguramente te puedes
preguntar qué ha pasado aquí bueno pues
realmente lo que pasó es que todas estas
coordenadas las escalamos por un factor
de 3 así que realmente este parece ser
nuestra respuesta cómo puedo saber eso
bueno pues mira lo siguiente este es el
punto 11 y bien a éste lo matamos al
punto 33 al punto 33
así que sí aquí tengo 1 2 3 y aquí 123
entonces llegamos justo acá al punto 33
justo aquí ahora tengo el 1 menos 1 y
este es el mapeo al 3 menos tres así que
estoy justo por acá después tengo el
menos 11 y ahí se lo mandamos al menos
33 a ese nos olvidemos tengo el menos 11
es lo mandamos al menos 33 ok estamos
justo por aquí y bueno para finalizar
claro tenemos al menos uno menos uno que
lo más veamos al menos tres menos tres
así que en definitiva este diagrama mi
segundo diagrama va a ser nuestra
respuesta porque este es el que
representa esta matriz transformación
temp
aplicada al cuadrilátero rojo